any wind welcome to this video playing
Margo set the right number and yes it is
okay try a French usually it doesn't
work out that well but I have an idea I
actually didn't want to do that that was
stupid
anyway it's a playable variation here
what I have on the board not entirely
terrible but ahead of it I wanted to
play a different line anyway
got a bit confused
okay yeah so here the main problem for
black is the absolute lack of
development and this is why I'm a little
bit skeptical about c5 but yeah I have
to do this at some point
here we go
why here he goes yeah
it looks a bit shaky everything well
that was a quick decision really is it I
thought that Bishop was really annoying
but maybe him 9f5 was too too disturbing
or anything
I'm sure anyway let's see what happens
93 okay my bishop he is hanging on a six
so I probably have to take yeah the
question is one question is if I take
now and deform
one disturbing point is Vigo g6 which is
generally speaking a move that I would
like to play then he might take on c5 b
takes and then Knight to e4 and then
there's threats on f66 and c5 which is a
bit much
knight c6 I think he will probably be
able to play a quick f5 even though I
can cancel long against that yeah maybe
maybe it's a vampire that me playing the
Frenchie is a recipe for disaster
I simply cannot play this opening I
don't know why you bet see people very
strong players play it I oftentimes
think yes this is an opening I should
really be able to play and you have some
some strategic GU ideas you have complex
porn structures and maybe I'm just
completely not understanding what I'm
good at I thought I could but to play
they cannot play the softening yeah yeah
yeah I was thinking and this is probably
now sounding a little bit if him that if
I cancel long e 5 is weak this is true
what I probably getting checkmated as
usual
yeah my king is weak I know
initially I wanted to play D takes
bishop takes but g7 was hanging so and
if I in it takes Bishop takes yeah would
be okay but g7 is just hanging there for
my originally intended continuation was
a total joke one thing I know if I get
to an ending I'm in excellent shape
the big issue ever is I probably I have
to get there first like in an ending my
pawn Center is strong my mother pawn
here is a weakness and so on but you
know have to get there first
so anyway
mmm yeah let's get out of this nightie
for stuff instead I'm getting in tonight
b5 which is not okay so he and then they
blended by five okay
he seems to be happy with the draw my
position wise I'm also happy with the
drama but yeah I thought I thought 94
could be and then Queen a6 is hitting me
that is helpful
94 should even trade more stuff
yeah traits you more this man breaking
the D fall 12 seconds
twelve seconds is plenty
my mousou night now I check on every one
and a half 92 yeah so it that helped a
lot eh blunder to piece I mean this line
you would be six I think it's actually
quite interesting um not like it's not
great but it has an interesting it's an
interesting features here with this
funny retreat move what black is arguing
is that in this close structure
neither the night nor the Queen is
ideally placed and you you want to yeah
put me a place he five later yeah okay
it must be a bit better for white for
sure it's a bits playable I guess Bishop
a6 looks normal to me computer doesn't
like it okay I'm more interested in the
in the coming positions like 92
I went c5 which is debatable it really
is because I I mean I can't play it
later I have to play c5 sometime but I
can play it a lot later if I want and
maybe the the whole development is to to
legging with c5 computer actually
already wants to take and probably like
this and d5 him and this is extremely
dangerous
I have no development I mean I moved the
Queen basically at a couple of points so
c5 is probably not a good choice if 196
yeah yeah I felt I could be okay by d7
and be sure
7s actually also an engine news takes
here
c4 Wow Wow
I had to tap move to play
I completely understand why it's good
once you know once the engine points it
out but you play Bishop a6 the whole
time for the sole idea to trade this bad
piece and then you play c4 and you don't
trade but it is strong it is extremely
strong actually because I have this pawn
storm idea and white currently I am on
f5 so then he cannot go f5 and I can
even play g6 at some stage to just stop
it totally and then nothing happens yeah
and I have before before and this is an
automatic attack it's going to be very
strong tough tough to play yeah it's
kind of it doesn't follow a logical yeah
it doesn't follow the the path the game
has taken so far okay look cakes and
here the issue is simply the time and
it's got a fire and me and my
development okay I played knight c6 and
yeah this is a problem after f5 yeah I
made a silly mistake I was intending to
do this and then cancelling along with
I'm simply dropping g7 it was some very
stupid so I had to take with the pawn
and now after a 5 Wow
ok I can so long thanks and again if I
get an endgame yeah my position is is
fantastic probably winning yeah because
my e6 pawn is not weak at all his a5
phone aways extremely weak and his
Knights are quite awkwardly placed but
it's all a bunch of nonsense if you
never get there the engine actually
points out this move which is
I could have killed me plain and simple
yeah when it looks very shaky
Queeny to was played no I'm okay
I'll see for it's not bad you have 95 as
suspected yeah now we hit the
self-destruct button here with Knight
takes e5 white is so better with my
chief on and it's just here we'll hope
that was just a blunder I think this
line with b6 is a recommendation of
Romanian when master marine and a recent
I'm not sure if he's already released it
he's got some French thing some French
project are going and I think he
recommends that it's an interesting line
for a strategic player maybe but yeah
again as you see I cannot do it I'm just
playing it terribly yeah thanks a lot
for watching